I think you could win mayor Chicago man
I don't want to be married what was the
last mayor was it Lori Lightfoot was
that shout out to Brandon Johnson oh
that's my boy is he the new mayor he's
the new mayor and uh the previous mayor
she was a hilarious person to watch
online her suits were really uh she was
like a meme yo there was that there was
did you ever see the the there was like
the interaction between her and some
like some guy on Yelp I didn't see that
it was so funny she just wasn't
she didn't have a constituency and she
wasn't open to addressing what was
really going on like when she had a
conversation set up with me
she um found out you know that I was
very critical of the police that's her
name right Lori Life For Life yeah she
found out I was so critical as police so
she just canceled the conversation
because she wasn't willing to like
actually
discuss what's going on in the city you
know I mean Chicago is a city with
so many harsh realities that it's like
how could we ever move forward if we
don't face those realities I think we
have a lot of subcultures and ideas in
our culture that are destroying us too
like op culture the idea of Ops is one
way that we've been brainwashed in
Chicago and in every hood and in rap
music
to believe that we are innately against
or enemies of ourselves it's almost like
we're staring in the mirror pointing a
gun at ourself because we've been taught
that you're from this block I'm from
this block you will inherit that we are
Ops we are enemies and so we romanticize
it but I think in many ways we've been
misled and it's just a manifestation of
our own self-hatred we've been taught to
hate ourselves and so we turn it into oh
you my op even though you look just like
me and you're from the same
circumstances as me right but you're
from a different block two streets away
we don't own these projects right we
don't own these Section Eight houses we
don't own these vacant Lots we don't own
these liquor stores we don't own these
gas stations but we die for them every
day it doesn't make sense there's so
much miseducation and misinformation so
I'm saying we need to dispel and
dissipate the whole op culture the whole
idea it's exhausting man and I'm like
you know me I'm a huge hip-hop head but
like I am so disconnected
from so much of the politics in that
world I know there's other platforms
that are notable that like dive more
into that [__] and I'm just like
like when a guy from Chicago comes on my
show like I don't usually I don't know
what the [__] I'm not even interested in
talking about any of that stuff but
that's good bro that's good because a
lot of people like man a lot of guys I
see the interviews and
you know they
they like just try to stand on that
um and
try to force these artists to speak
about their Ops or who they've bickered
with and who they have beef with and
then if they don't want to you know like
either take offense or you know it's
like
I think that the role of a journalist or
uh a steward of culture as as you are
and people that are your contemporaries
is one that has to be treated with a lot
of respect and a lot of reverence man
because
there's so much influence and it's like
this music that we make that we aspire
to rise from out of the gutter with and
we put our heart and our soul into it
and oftentimes it's a reflection of good
and bad everything that's around us
manic it can bring a lot a lot of murder
behind it and it's the people that sit
in that seat that can either
help us to transcend and express what
you know what is important to us and
what's valuable to us or try to chain us
to where we came from and it's like man
I know it's clickbait I know it helps
yeah I mean it's yeah to me it's like yo
There's real like lives
to me it's like I got to be able to why
you want me to talk about and why you
want me to talk about it on record
that's the thing I think is crazy about
hip-hop is like
I think that we've reached an error and
an age when
snitching on yourself and
self-incrimination
people uh encouraging you to incriminate
yourself is at an all-time high you get
on here and they want you to
give a detailed account of what crimes
you've committed I'll have to stop
artists and interviews sometimes and
I'll have to hit them with the
allegedly allegedly yeah allegedly
because like I might get allegedly
whatever it's such a catch-22 though
because
we've seen those things go viral so if
you're a young artist or a young [__]
in the street aspiring to be an artist
and you see somebody catch a murder and
that Skyrocket their career yeah that
can teach your career up if you can talk
about it or you that can really excite
somebody to think okay well maybe this
is a way that I can change my life my
family's life because it's working for
everybody else being on Front Street
about some Street [__] or going to do
some Street [__] making the music about
it for sure and the record labels profit
from us
you're incentivized to do that because
it's good for your career in theory good
for your life it's not good for the
bigger picture but you know what was
super wild to me man was like realizing
that everywhere is not like this like
not even in hip-hop you know being in
South Africa which is also a pretty
violent explosive Place yeah in its ways
um
but learning that their hip-hop scene is
like
that doesn't fuel your career that
doesn't help you then you're seeing it's
harder to Market and I was like it's
crazy because it's the opposite in
America it's like if you're stamped and
your criminal history is solidified then
this can be the main it can it can give
you a career but I do legitimacy but I
do think it also puts a ceiling on you
because there are certain like like [__]
rolling loud like now you know they'll
they'll not book an artist because the
hip-hop police in New York is on their
ass you know some of these drug guys in
New York that have issues and my whole
approach to the whole situation is like
I've had very few situations where I've
had any sort of conversations that were
like beef driven and if it ever gets
brought up it'd be because
like there was two there's two guys from
Jacksonville that have like
Jacksonville's crazy and I I in our
interview because I know both of them I
know both the guys Julio and young and
Ace and the only time we touched on the
subject was like how do you guys like
squash this because you guys are from
the same city like is there a way to
ever put this behind you guys and set an
example you know what I mean like that
that that you guys could be bigger than
whatever has already happened because I
think that's really the hardest thing is
like one convincing artists that like
yes
when you're on YouTube and the algorithm
is feeding you these weird ass Hood
documentaries that these faceless
YouTubers make so strange that [__] is
so there's a whole Mega micro economy on
YouTube of faceless YouTube creators
that just do Hood comments it's crazy
you don't know what these guys look like
maybe somewhere in Utah
it's real [__] it's like hip-hop is in
that way like trauma porn for people
outside of our community you know we
don't need to sit and watch that because
that's going on in our real life but
like you said if you're an artist and
like you're trying to get a buzz it's
like almost like well how do I make
people give a [__] and well I know that
this is what people will care about but
then there's real life consequences to
that you might lose your life your
friend might lose your life
you know to me it's like yo how do we
try to get past because like you said
the op culture to me it's like a cloud
over hip hop the last like five years
that's just like oh it's just too much
sometimes man like I'm exhausted by it
bro like I just feel like we as black
men have to normalize conflict
resolution we have to normalize
peacemaking we have to normalize letting
things go letting things go is the
importance we have to recognize that
oftentimes the real strength the real
power is in letting something go that's
much more difficult I had to learn that
it takes a lot more out of me to
Let It Go than it does for me to take it
to a violent space because that's the
way and you're carrying conflict with
you at all times subconsciously you
don't even realize it I had a situation
man in Chicago where you know something
from my past came back and someone that
had robbed me and was very close to me
and
um
you know ultimately pop back up with
like a real disrespectful aggressive uh
attitude and approach and
in that moment
I decided to give it absolutely no power
to respond not at all so when he was as
close to me as you are now telling me
what he gonna do see me here there I
just said
may God bless you bro got up and left
yeah you know started to hit my phone
I said God bless you blocked it move on
hit me from different numbers but what I
learned was
in exercising that restraint which was
so difficult for me and putting it to a
space of God and prayer and just letting
it go
the situation fell a part of its own
weight so much more easily than if I had
engaged it in a violent way and but
we're not we're not taught that that
conflict resolution and non-violent
conflict resolution is ultimately
more beneficial because a lot of times
in the past I would handle something
differently and I would go handily in a
violent way and now look next thing you
know bootleg KFC is me on TV with a gun
case because I'm in the spiral of
Revenge paranoia I'm keeping this on me
all the time because
somebody might come and retaliate for
something that I've done right I can't
create the right way because you're
always parent because I tell people when
you got beef with like you know what my
Studios at it's a subconscious [__]
because you're always on like kind of
your guard's always up well that's the
thing that we experience man it's like
we live in a constant state of survival
mode and the Brain
reacts to that like we're in the wild at
fear of lions attacking us our amygdala
is responsible for the cortisol that
keeps us in fight or flight moment and
in our communities in our neighborhoods
were always in fight-or-flight mode
because you're always ready to either
kill or be killed so especially while
you beefing with people and experiencing
the opposite it's like you're amygdala
and your cortisol is overactive so
you're constantly tense you're
constantly stressed you're ready to go
at any time and
for me it's hard to like
from a place of peace and like really be
focused on what's important when I'm
doing that and it just ultimately it
[__] the money up it [__] the spirit
up [__] the energy for sure you know
find yourself in a jail cell or you know
worse